this exercise is actually really helpful
and what i ask them to do is to sit down
and imagine their character is in a room
with someone else in the movie that they
trust
how much easier is it for the writer if
they know
from the beginning what the character
wants
a million times easier
it's a million times easier if you kind
of know what the character wants
but there's always a starting point you
think you know what they want at the
beginning and you start writing with
that and then it can shift
you know and so um
i think it's the most important thing
like i said earlier you know
when i do consultations with people it's
the singular most popular problem in the
script is what do they want
how are they trying to get it you know
what are they doing to try to get it
how does that make them face something
in themselves and how do they grow and
do they finally get this thing or do
they get it in a way that they didn't
expect
so um i think i think i always try to
start out like what do they want because
i've learned over the years like i need
to know what that is because that's the
engine that drives their actions through
the story
and when i don't know that and i start
to write i'm just kind of like just
driving over here i'm driving over here
i don't know you know it just it ends up
being i throw out a lot of pages
so i think you can start like what is
their emotional need you know do they
want love do they want revenge
what is it that's driving them and then
what's the specific thing they think is
gonna get is gonna satisfy that need and
how do they pursue that
and um you may start with that and you
may shift it you know as you start to
write you realize oh that's not what
they want at all they want this other
thing so then you're gonna have to go
back
and kind of you know reverse engineer
what you did but it's okay that's the
process you know and a lot of times
characters um goals shift in the movie
you know like in get out which is a
great movie you know chris he wants to
go impress her family in the middle of
the in the middle of the movie his goal
shifts to like i need to get out of here
they're gonna hijack my body and my
brain
right so so that that shifts
in in the story but but that's good
that's okay but he still has a goal
throughout that drives him and you've
said before that sometimes when you sit
down to write that your character
sometimes starts to tell you what they
want in a sense yeah
i just had an experience with this barf
thing that i did this thing that i just
vomited out like i'm just gonna write
right right and i was just like i kind
of had the plot in my head because again
this side the left side is so dominant
in my brain and i was just like okay
this is when this happens and then
suddenly she's in the middle of the
scene and like there's a flashback where
somebody's she's curled up in a ball in
the bathroom and someone's throwing
movie magazines at her
from the 1940s and i was like
then i went back into the scene i'm like
well that just happened i
i don't know what happened to her but
something happened to her and then i
kept writing and then again when i went
back that was where all that whole
backstory is what the whole thing is
really about
why she's doing what she's doing
what she's gonna have to face you know
in the story
but that was never in my brain that that
would ever happen i would that there
were that flashback was just going to
pop up in the middle of my writing
but it was great they she started
talking to me she started telling me
stuff that happened to her and i was
like okay
what if we can't figure out what the
character wants
oh wow yeah
what if you can't figure out what the
character wants
again a very common issue right
um some strategies that you might do to
try to figure out what the character
wants
um is to figure out um what they're
afraid of
what are they afraid of like what are
they scared of
and what do they want
that's in contrast to that you know does
the could their want come from wanting
the opposite of that fear
do you know what i mean if they're
afraid let's say they were had a
traumatic past or traumatic childhood
you know um
could
they really want just the perfect family
you know could you start from fear and
generate a want as the opposite of that
that's one way to kind of try to
generate some ideas about you know what
your character could want um one thing
that i often do with my clients and my
students is
i have them write a monologue
and
monologues in movies are
we're not supposed to write monologues
it's one of the rules but you know what
this exercise is actually really helpful
and what i ask them to do is to sit down
and imagine their character is in a room
with someone else in the movie that they
trust another character that they trust
and that other character says
what do you want
and this character
tells that other character what they
want
and
i
i ask the writers to use all their five
senses to describe this dream that they
have
and just to allow that character to talk
to the writer and describe what they
want with no preconceptions
and usually out of and i say write for
five minutes and don't stop
so just stream of consciousness i want
this and you know somewhere in there is
the is a kernel of something that they
can actually grab onto
and hold on to so again giving an
invitation to your character to speak to
you about what they want
so if they don't know what the character
wants it doesn't necessarily mean they
need to abandon it that that character
is not really connecting with them no
okay no it's just that they don't know
yet
they have to listen
they aren't listening they're trying to
like put things on the character you
know if you step into the character and
let them talk
they will tell you things
you know so let them tell someone else
in the movie what they want
what are the ways a writer can create
stakes for their character
oh great question
so obviously stakes are really important
um for characters because they create
suspense and tension around
um the goal right so if they don't
achieve what they want to achieve
something terrible will happen they will
lose something
there linda seeger wrote this really
great book called how to make a good
script great it's not just for rewriting
you can use it to write a first draft
but she actually has a really great
chapter on stakes and what she came up
with is a list
of what is a list of stakes for any
human being and i i'm going to try to
remember off the top of my head but it's
like survival
love and belonging
security
security
um
uh the aesthetic which is a sense of
order control
um
self-actualization which is
self-expression so
the loss of any one of these things on
this list is devastating for a human
right survival physical survival oh my
god i'm dead right love and belonging if
we don't have love and belonging
we're basically dead
safety and security we also need that if
we don't have it
it's going to be bad right so all of
these stakes
um
one way to think about that is to look
at her list and i think it's online
somewhere if people want to check it out
um
but but look at that list and and think
about it in relation to my character's
goal if they don't like for example if i
don't make that person love me what will
i lose
love you know which ones on this list am
i gonna lose
and if you if you watch a lot of movies
and you think about this and you think
about the stakes that the writers have
set up for their main characters
usually it's everything on that list
except for one or two things
they stack the stakes for the main
character so it's just not love and
belonging it's also safety and security
it's also self-actualization it's
actually you know um maybe later in the
movie something happens where now it's
survival i'm gonna die they pile on the
stakes and every good writer has to be
able to articulate
what the character's gonna lose if they
don't get what they want
again everything is connected to the
character and their goal
so if they don't get this thing
what will be lost
and the more you can stack those stakes
for your character the more tension and
suspense um
and kind of like we're just gonna be
like oh no they're not gonna if they
it's just gonna create in the audience
this
like connection and fear that they're
not going to get what they want which is
what you want in the story
so just like the is that maslow's
hierarchy of needs yeah so i think at
the at the very bottom of it or
area i'm trying to think if i flipped it
so self-actualization i think is is the
last one yes and then survive safety
and survival yeah okay and linda seeger
created the screenwriting version of
that list nice yeah okay and so if you
took like a jenga piece if we take one
of those away then that that's going to
raise the stakes no matter what it is
yeah
okay yeah interesting yeah like like you
know um i was thinking about um the
movie coco you know the pixar movie coco
about the little kid miguel who has to
go to the land of the dead so he can
find his ancestors so that he can become
a musician which is what he's meant to
be right
and i went through um linda seeger's
list of all those stakes you know um
and he had everything except one
and it that's just good writing you know
he's not just gonna physically possibly
die he's gonna lose his family he's
gonna lose safety he's gonna um not be
who he's meant to be like everything
like this kid is gonna it's gonna be
horrible
if he doesn't achieve his goal
um and so again the writer has to be
able to understand and articulate you
know what's at stake for the character